my parents are both immigrants my mom is
french-canadian
my dad is french they immigrated here to
the united states
and that story of immigrating here and
kind of hustling and trying to make this
thing work
i think was ingrained in me in many ways
[Music]
my name is alex larue i'm the chief
technology officer
and co-founder of icon icon is a
construction technologies company
and our first product is called the
vulcan it's a giant 3d printer that
prints
homes
i was about to graduate from college and
i was trying to figure out what i should
do
after graduation and i was kind of
basically on a research project
of trying to figure out what's like the
cool next thing and 3d printing
i realized was like one of those things
at that time small scale 3d printers i
just thought
were very limited in terms of what you
could do with them but i thought that
maybe if we scaled
up the printers on the order like two
orders of magnitude
really some interesting things could
start to happen and so that's what i
basically did for the next two years
went heads down and built some really
really large scale 3d printers
and with these printers we ended up
printing the first permanent 3d printed
house
in the united states in 2018 now
20 homes have been 3d printed across a
couple different countries some in
mexico some united states
some in california what that allows us
to do is basically put these people who
used to be in
these really terrible conditions now in
these safe
beautiful comfortable secure homes
at a low cost so that's really a
compelling mission
before i started icon i started four
other companies
and they didn't end up making it but by
starting those four companies i really
quickly figured out
what it was like to be onto something
and not onto something
if i were to give one piece of advice to
entrepreneurs in this industry
it's that there's no such thing as
overnight success
you know these things take time we first
started prototyping
and trying to make this real in 2014
that's now
seven years ago and we're just now
starting to see the
surface of the success that we're gonna
have
you